good morning and welcome to the Royal
Swedish Academy of Sciences today it's
time to announce the Prize in Economic
Sciences this price is funded by the
central bank of Sweden the sperry
districts bank and awarded by the Royal
Swedish Academy of Sciences in memory of
Alfred Nobel and this award is the 48th
since its conception in 1969
I am your Ron Hansen and the
secretary-general of the Academy
and with me today is on my left
professor param Barry who is the
chairman of the economics Prize
Committee and on my right side professor
too much forum with a member of the
committee and an expert in the field of
this year's prize this year's price is
about contract or its economy please
hands are on contract Connelly evita
scopes academy nobis loot that at Stella
is various Riksbank sprees he economics
Nathan Scott till alfred nobel's mean
for all sugar and rosetta stone till
oliver hard rock banked Holmstrom 3rd
terrace be drug till contracts terrine
the Royal Swedish Academy of Sciences
has decided to award the various
Riksbank prize in Economic Sciences in
memory of Alfred Nobel for 2016 - oliver
heart and bank Holmstrom for their
contributions to contract theory you can
see the new laureates on the screen
above me
Oliver Hart was born 1948 in
Londyn but get worked in the United
States since the 1980s and he's
currently the Andrew Fuhrer professor of
economics at Harvard University in
Cambridge Massachusetts in the u.s. Bank
column strim was born in 1949 in
Helsinki in Finland but yes had his
career in the United States
he is the Paul Samuelson professor of
economics at the Massachusetts Institute
of Technology also in Cambridge
Massachusetts he is a foreign member of
our Academy but he has not participated
in any aspect of the prize work or the
Academy's work in general in recent
years that was the announcement and we
will now hear more about our new
laureates and their work from Professor
param vayu of the economics prize
committee pad so this prize is about
contracts and contract is really a very
fundamental phenomenon that I think
affects all of us in society and
probably most of us have some kind of
insurance for properly for our car for
our house that means we've entered an
insurance contract with an insurance
company all of us or many of us at least
has borrowed to buy this house or car
which means we have a loan contract with
a bank that we are party to when we
bought our house or car we wrote the
purchasing contract with the seller of
this of this property and if we have a
job we probably have an employment
contract with our employer okay so all
of us are affected by contracts and
actually contracts is broader than this
because many phenomena many institutions
we see in society or actually a
contractor can be analyzed with contract
theory so for example when we own
something when we have property rights
to something that's the type of contract
that says what we can do with our
property if we you know the political
Constitution in the country
type of contract between the state and
the citizens of that country so this is
very fundamental and the theories that
heart and Holmstrom have have developed
are incredibly important for us to
understand these types of contracts and
institutions so one aspect of contracts
that's you know a lot of us think about
when we think about contracts is that
they're about you know sharing financial
returns from some cooperation okay so it
basically says if we have a contract who
should pay whom when and how much
now from a theoretical standpoint you
can think about these as what we call a
principal and agent problem okay so a
principal would be for example if you
think about an employment contract the
principal would be the employer who
hires someone to do some job so the
person who's hired is the agent the
agent is supposed to do some job on
behalf of the principal and what you
have to do is design a contract the
compensation for this agent that they
sort of design in the best way and it
turns out these contracts typically have
to balance two different forces okay so
the first one is that since the
principal since the employer doesn't
necessarily see what the agent or the
employee is doing all the time you have
to have a contract that gives incentives
for this agent to act in the interest of
this principal okay to give the
incentive part but the other part which
is in conflict with this sometimes is
that you don't want to put too much risk
on the agent okay the employee is not
going to be very happy if the cave you
know goes up and down the flock chase
all the time so you also want to provide
some risk sharing some insurance to this
agent so if we take in an insurance
contract for example okay we would love
if the insurance company fully covered
our losses if we have an accident or if
our house burns down we would like to
get everything covered so we have no
risk but the problem is that that's
going to give us the wrong incentives
potentially because you know if we know
we're fully covered we're not going to
take as well care of our property as we
otherwise would have that's why we have
you know deductibles and co-payments
right we have to pay you lip
that ourselves if we have a loss the
insurance company doesn't doesn't cover
everything and that's to give us the
right incentives to be careful okay
the risk versus incentives so this is
where Bank Holmstrom's contributions are
in understanding this principal-agent
problem and how to design contracts so
this is an old problem I mean already
Adam Smith's talked about you know the
principal-agent problem but this
research really took off
thanks to Bank Holmstrom's contributions
and starting in the late nineteen eight
nineteen seventies and onwards and he
basically has a number of different
research contributions that highlights
all sorts of different important aspects
of how to do these contracts what
information do you want to pay base
performance on what do you do when an
agent has to be incentivized to do too
many - - lots of different things not
just one thing how do you incentivize a
team you know so maybe people are
working together to produce something
how do you think about giving the right
incentives over time for example how
does your future career prospects affect
your incentives to work today okay so to
be a little bit more concrete let's
think about an example that I think a
lot of people are familiar with how do
we pay managers and CEOs of big
companies okay so this is a principal
agent problem the principal are you know
the shareholders okay they want to hire
this agent the CEO to act in their
interest to create as much value for the
shareholders as possible for example so
it turns out you can apply Holmstrom
different theories on lots of aspects of
this problem so for example the
informativeness principle which is the
famous result of Holmstrom that talks
about you know what information should
you bathe say the bonus on ok one
implication of that for example is that
it might seem natural to reward a CEO if
the profits of their company is high ok
but that means that's not the full story
because if we just face bonus on the
profits of their own company then we're
going to be paid
the CEO in many times just because be
there being lucky or punish them because
they're unlucky if you run an oil
company you might be more profitable
just because the oil price goes up
that's just luck we don't want to reward
the CEO for that okay so that's an
implication of the informativeness
principle another natural example is
that you know a CEO needs to do many
different things to create value in the
company so for example they we might
want them to really make sure that this
year's profits are high but we might
also want to make sure that they take
the best long-run decisions in the
company or we invest in let's say R&D
your long term investments where the
profits may show up you know long far
into the future okay so how do you
balance these incentives for you know
this year's profits versus long term
value for the company and one
interesting finding here is that you
know typically it's easier to measure
profits today compared to long-run value
okay so there's a temptation to base the
bonus on the thing you can observe or
easiest measure right the profits today
but that's it has a problem because if
you only base the the bonus on today's
profits then maybe everything that CEO
will focus on is just this year's
profits and forget about long-run
investments that are important for the
firm so in that situation maybe you
can't have any bonus at all not even on
short-term profits if you want to have
the right balance with incentives and
the third example is this career
concerns model of Holmstrom which
basically says that when you're young
you get an incentive even if you don't
have a bonus you have an incentive to do
the right thing because you might get
promoted in at the pay raise in the
future but this also tells you that if
you think about a CEO maybe having a big
bonus or performance pay is much more
important when they're getting old and
closer to retirement
compared to when they're young and
motivate our incentivized by future
career prospects so that sort of
summarizes being Holmstrom's
contribution now Oliver Hart introduced
another aspect of contracting that
turned out to be very important and
which has to do with incomplete
contracts okay so if we look at a
contract
it just doesn't just specify you know
payments between people but it also says
who should have the right to decide on
things in this cooperation okay now why
are these decision rights in these
contracts well it has to do with the
fact that you can't specify everything
in a contract it will become impossible
you know they they'll become larger than
that one okay there's so many things
that can happen in the future that we
can't even imagine and write down what
will happen in the contract so we can't
do that then we have to say okay what
happens if something unexpected or
unspecified happens who has the right to
decide what to do then okay that's where
these decision rights come in so what
contracts also do is that they decide
who should or or they allocate these
decision rights between the contracting
parties who has the right to make the
decision when we haven't specified it
beforehand and this is really what in
complete contracting theory is about so
again there were sort of informal
arguments of how to understand decision
rights ownership property rights in this
context but there wasn't any formal
theory before Oliver Hart and his
co-authors developed this starting in
the mid-1980s and the idea here again is
that when contracts are incomplete you
haven't specified anything then you have
to write down who has the right to make
the decision okay or what to do now
having the right to make the decision
that gives you power okay and that power
helps you actually capture a bigger
piece of the cake in your relationship
okay so if you have the right to decide
if you own the assets then you're gonna
get the bigger reward from the
cooperation and that in turn affects
your incentives to for example invest in
this relationship so this is sort of the
the gist of the theory they first
applied it to the question of whether a
firm should own its supplier or not okay
so that's called vertical integration
but they just turned out this is an
incredibly rich theory to explain many
many different things
so to give you some examples this theory
was applied to understand you know what
is really the difference between the
firm and the market okay what kind of
transactions economic transactions
should better take place within firms
and which ones should occur in markets
it has been applied to understand this
financial contracting problem okay if we
want to borrow or get money from an
investor how do we write specify the
decision rights in that relationship it
can be applied to organization design so
who should have the right to decide
should the boss decide on everything or
should you delegate more to the
employees that's a problem you can
analyze with this theory and the last
one which I'm going to spend a little
bit more time on is the issue of
privatization okay so let's say your
government wants some public service to
be provided we can think about a prison
or you know healthcare hospital or a
school or you know garbage collection
okay should the government own this
service provider or should you write the
contract with a private service provider
okay now without in complete contracting
theory you really can't think about
ownership because so let's say that the
government wants to get both high
quality of this service but they also
want cost efficiency you don't want to
spend too much taxpayers money on
getting this service so you have these
two goals now let's say you could
measure some quality and you could
measure costs well then you would just
write a paper formance contract that
gives you know pace the provider more if
quality is high and costs are low and
less otherwise now in this world it
doesn't matter who owns it you could
have a government employee that has the
same pay performance contract as let's
say a private provider so to get
ownership to matter you really have to
be in the world where contracts are
incomplete you can't exactly specify in
a contract what good quality is okay for
example so this gives a role for
ownership and it's going to be very
different than if the government owns
the service provider or if it's private
service provider that you pay to do the
service so in general
it's very hard if you have a
government-owned service to provide good
incentives for either for cost-cutting
or quality and because it's very hard to
credibly reward government employees for
for cutting costs or improving quality
now that doesn't mean that private
ownership is always better so Hart's
model really tells you which type of
factors go in the direction of public or
private ownership so for example in the
situation where cost reductions can
really hurt quality okay well that would
push you more towards public ownership
and if innovations future innovations to
improve quality of services are really
important and very hard to specify well
that factor tends to move in the
direction of a private ownership in this
model and how competitive a private
market will be also turns out to be very
important if competition is not expected
to work very well well then that goes in
the direction of public ownership so
this isn't the model that says that one
thing is always better than the other
but it tells you that maybe you know
garbage collection has a different
optimal setup than let's say a prison
okay so to conclude this theory has
really been incredibly important not
just for economics but also for other
social sciences so everything ranging
from corporate governance and firms to
you know constitutional law and politics
can be analyzed for these kind of tools
and thanks to their research we now have
can analyze not just you know financial
terms you know who should get paid what
but also these control and decision
rights ownership property rights and and
other types of decision rights and
contracts and this theory is both
positive as we call it which means you
can explain the type of contracts we see
in society but it's also normative it
can actually help us write better
contracts both in public policy and in
private markets so that's it Thank You
patty
now we at this stage we may have one of
our laureates with us on a phone line
professor bank Holmes term good morning
professor Armstrong are you there good
morning I'm here very good this is John
Hanson of the Academy again and since we
spoke an hour ago I have moved to our
press conference and announced the price
to you and an dr. Hart are you ready to
take some questions from the journalists
yeah would it be okay in Swedish as well
as in English that's ok very good
who would like to start please I'll take
it in English congratulations how did
you react when you get the call from
Stockholm about an hour ago well I'm
very happy more questions yeah please
make another one you have studied you
haven't done research on contracts could
I ask you about bonuses for CEOs what do
you think should you give big bonuses to
CEOs well in in economics we don't
really take a stand on the size of the
the size of the bonuses though they seem
extraordinary high but mighty mighty
reach don't take take a stand on that as
much as it's study it's the question
about what what kind of structure should
be used and and in this regard I think
my personal view is that they are too
complicated today and and that on the
other hand what has been improved in
late years is the best put what's called
the vesting meaning that that they don't
get everything in in a very short period
they get things overtime and and so but
it's a very complicated problem
and one last question how do you feel
right now happy very lucky and grateful
to the committee and my colleague and
the coders and family and everybody more
questions gentleman over there
Hey yes Ben ocean from tears me up there
yeah thank the powerful sales campaign
tone oh goody bro yeah well bra till my
music get up this do ho so that in nokia
steel said it evicted before scalped for
Alpharetta from the privet on an exhibit
preset so do vote come a hurry buddy
mmm Italy visited well another
nourishment oh yeah but yeah Bernie are
using some an academic at the Berea so
mean yeah buddy are at the bathroom if
in window or the body ibly interfere
that we have in common
probably so high and they everybody for
this endeavor make sure these
genetically beautiful or somehow means
was like familiar for the talks today
are my body experience
yeah on force couple contracts to River
what turns with tummy area data from the
Indian art exhibit bloody they named it
if you have borne a son a footy that so
here you need a dad gay young for create
program and I am here no I didn't have
for the past two children attitude and
on into commentator further we have
singin among the flowers and the food
anna or the search for momentum are me
Oliver arterial on them have the clue
traitor
also Jesus at the head they I put him
behind it immense problematic a support
our our our doctoral
just little Egan the intima era of where
can we visit the use to second forum a
rock so but
peggeleh there I am today at how we did
didn't he prefer it has missed attack
anything therefore Thank You Mika back
lady over there hi congratulations I'm
certain access song from Green post and
CDR I freelance
I just like to ask you did you ever
expect this or ever think of you will
win the Nobel Prize
thank you well this professional and
being trained is obviously people talk
about it and I would say other people
have talked about it yes I certainly did
not expected and at least at least you
know at this time so I was very
surprised and very happy but I think
most people think thing to real
congratulations
I have a question concerning context
theory and that is when you look at the
incentives for the Adrian do you think
the difference between if the principle
is only shareholders illness or if
stakeholders including different parties
in society yes it would be it would make
a difference in the sense that you know
people that people who get to decide
incentive look at them from their own
angle but but one of the important
lessons for contract theory is that
whatever contract is right you always
have to think about the other parties
involved as well
so so you have to look at it more
broadly and just look at it you know
from the point of view of the
shareholder the tailhold of any sort is
much
liking the comp benefits that Walker has
to think about Metro about all the other
parties that are involved so it's not
it's not what we begin in economic fall
you know we are trying to maximize the
total pie meaning get it to be a bin bin
- welcome to everybody thank you the
gentlemen with a big camera over there
Dave Adkisson Associated Press so the
panel explains your work and the word
incentives came back frequently may I
ask you what was the incentive to begin
research in this area and what incentive
will this nobel prize bring you sir on
the first question the incentive to
study this came from before I became an
academic it was incidental that party
statement academics I went to Stanford
for one year one year social of exchange
it seems - and and I had realized that
in 70s you know the company I was
working for make its decisions and make
it to TV flash and and and that's when I
realized that the issue wasn't really
about you know the difficulty of coming
up with the best plan the bigger issue
was also to create incentives for people
to give the right in information that is
needed for this plant and and
incentivize them in general so that's
the regions of the idea and I was very
lucky that this happened to be an
interest in economics at the same time
when I came to Stanford
thank you
are there more questions yes clear our
banks Holstrom your working waterfront 8
billion or estudiar at contracts
theories best repo silver contract
already made an eggnog contract
then we move on or Milan or they are in
so it not be so focused all countries
that we think I put on myself among a
caucus on Vesta the most traded our last
LS and the quantity was instantly bad
and so so so the big there for a long
long long 60 will give somebody - they
allow for so in many developed nations
cup we be blondie afraid ma comparable
some mention ideas are to land was until
the men we explore methods that the
units of course all last question brief
question from the lady over there yes
hello congratulations mister Holmstrom
louise something made them from sky dog
blood at Stockholm I have two questions
the first is with your way of thinking
about contracts could how could that be
applied to political situations as for
the say for the upcoming US election now
between a politician and then a large
number of people all the citizens and
the the second question is whether you
if you do have an idea but coming up
from your early experience with Nokia
and now in Sweden with Ericsson having
some troubles
do you see could has there been can you
are a research sort of explain what has
happened in these companies in any way
let me take the first question because
it's more creative in some sense you
know that relates to the political
incentive so so they mentioned my book
on career concern that mr. Babington
studies work that applies very much to a
broad range of things to but it's not
both money it is about what people's
ambitions are and motivation for why
they are doing things and and their you
know such things that ability if you
look at them now they are all on TV and
touch that
on TV and having everybody look at at
them perform say this base those have
both good intentions and bad intentions
involved so you know what because in
places the incentives or these
motivations they have very complicated
to deal with and they they drive bad
behavior days are good behaviors well
thank you very much professor Holmstrom
I'm afraid we'll have to stop there
there will be more opportunities to
interview professor Armstrong when it
comes to Stockholm in December so thank
you very much and see you in December
thank you
any quick questions to the panel if not
yes yes we have reached Oliver Hart and
he was also very happy and pleased and
they both of them expressed that there
were or delighted to be sharing the
price with each other they appreciate
each other as colleagues and friends so
with that we'll close this part of the
press conference and now it's time for
individual interviews with experts and
committee members for those of you who
requested interviews and then you're all
welcome back on I think a December 7th
thank you
professor param berry you're the member
of the economic science Prize Committee
this year's Prize in Economic Sciences
is awarded to only Berhad and banked
Holmstrom for the researching contract
theory why context area because contract
theory first of all when you start
thinking about it contracts are really
fundamental we see them everywhere in
society all of us are engaged in
different types of contracts many
institutions we see in society you can
also think about contracts like
constitutions or property rights and
those kind of things so one thing it's
important the second thing is that this
is a theory that really has given rise
to lots of other applications so in many
many fields not just in economics but in
law and politics people actually use
these theories to understand
is this a big big area of research and
economic sciences it's huge
I would say it's literally huge and it
really started taking off first with you
know this classical contract theory that
Bank Holmstrom developed and then with
the incomplete contracting the area
Oliver Hart both of those strands have
proven incredibly influential across
social sciences
give an example of the value of this
type of research if it can be more
concrete so well I mentioned to two
examples in the press conference one is
you know thinking about how to decide
pay for for example for CEOs and firms
you know how do you balance incentive
pay which makes maybe them be more
motivated but how do you avoid you know
bonuses and incentive pay leading to
wrong decisions being made in companies
so the theory is super useful to
understand that problem not just to
explain what happens but actually help
shareholders or corporate boards to
design better contracts as well the
second example I mentioned was you know
ownership okay so how do we think about
ownership does it matter who owns what
okay
so to be very concrete privatization
right does it matter whether a provider
of public services is owned by the
government or owned by a private
contractor and to understand this
problem and the trade-offs there this
theory that Oliver Hart developed an
incomplete contracting is absolutely
crucial to think about that as the
ordinary consumer like you and me who
sometimes sign contracts and I think you
learn about this yeah well I think we
understand for example why when we have
an insurance for our house and it burns
down what we have a loss why doesn't the
insurance company cover everything okay
so we would like our you know to be
fully covered but we usually have a
deductible or a co-payment okay that may
be the first whatever loss we have to
pay ourselves and contract theory
explains for example why that's the case
because if we were fully covered let's
say our car insurance paid for the full
value of our car well then maybe we
wouldn't care about whether we locked
the car or not or someone stole it
because you know we would anyway get a
new car from the insurance guy so these
two things it's just giving us insurance
but also making sure we have the right
incentives to be careful the trade-off
between these two things
thing we can understand and analyze with
contract insurance compasses companies
interested in this field research know
that insurance companies are hugely
interested in this type of research
actually a lot of the insurance
companies were among the first people or
real world people who really started
thinking about contract theory and how
to balance insurance and incentives and
contracts are sometimes program just
economists economy and money is there
any political lessons to be learned
about this type of research there's
actually lots of political lessons
because a lot of political institutions
you can think about as contracts between
you know the politicians and the
citizens and politicians we believe are
very much affected by incentives maybe
not you know not necessarily monetary
incentives and but you know carry our
incentives right so for example this
theory tells us how you know politicians
might have very different motivations at
different points in their career for
example you could also tell us you know
what's the best institutional setup
should we have you know power balance
between a parliament and
and the government and the High Court or
you know I should organize these things
so contract theory is very applicable to
all of these problems
you know this this person's a little
please tell us who are only their heart
and Bank hallstrm tell us about the
courier son since research so banged
Holmstrom is born in finland actually
speaks swedish he moved to Stanford as
an exchange student and you know he had
AI think anticipated working in his you
know in the business world but he was
interested in understanding problems
that he's on the business were problems
with you know how do you motivate people
you know how do you get the right
corporate culture in the company and
then when he came to Stanford he was
lured into doing research on this and
then ended up you know staying in the US
and becoming you know warm famous
researcher on this oliver heart is also
european he's born in in britain he
started out actually doing a very
theoretical work on market equilibrium
and so on
but he at some point started become
interested in what ownership was you
know how should we think about ownership
what is that and and you know why do why
do we say ownership and decision rights
and contracts and that really switched
him to this field of incomplete
contracting that you know it became
world famous for and was awarded and I
just wonder has the Lord's written some
books or something that someone can
begin to if they're really interested in
there well they both written some good
sort of overview articles actually
together they have a nice overview of
contract theory it may be a bit academic
but Oliver Hart has written a few books
also on on incomplete contract if you
have the press release we actually have
a few links to interviews and
biographies that are more accessible to
research is one final question question
are they happy to about the news I think
they are very happy obviously they're
very happy to get the award but both of
them actually emphasized how happy they
were to share the prize with the other
person so I think they they are very
pleased right thank you very much
pass them by
you